so let's go ahead and do this I need a
bit more space but I want to leave all
that stuff meth so let's put this away
I'll leave my perfect slice let's now
compute this volume okay excuse me now
if you haven't drawn this diagram
already I think it's advisable to do
that and just like before right I want
to be able to say well I know all of the
dimensions of this thing I'm going to
put them on there right so I thought
this is sometimes your call well I
really should go to the edge sorry I've
got this cylindrical shell and all i
need is num1 a radius but this radius is
just how far away you are from the
origin in this case it's just equal to X
yes and just keep in mind like we saw
before it might not be quite that simple
suppose you are not rotating about the
quarter access like we were here suppose
the y axis suppose you're rotating
around like something off to the edge so
for instance if the axis here was not x
equals zero suppose it was x equals 2
right you're just going to have to say
well this is not just X it's the
distance of x from two so for instance
you might have a radius that's 2 minus X
that's the distance of x from to does
that make sense so in this case we have
a very very simple example partly
because the first one I'm showing you
but you can get ones that are a little
bit more complicated you just have to
think carefully about just don't
automatically go here in the same way
you need a hike for this thing but again
in our case because we've just got this
function that's very nice a symmetrical
the height is just Y which is four x
squared minus X to the 4 okay one last
thing I'm going to put on here if you
have the center of that circular
cross-section there what we really need
to work out this volume is this guide
which is the circumference so this is 2
pi x instead of two panel well I told a
lie don't know peace it's a volume so I
had one too sorry 12 a third quantity
because it's a three-dimensional thing
name
me in this case Delta X now can I
emphasize right you must you must
absolutely do this I did said it before
the extension to syllabus actually says
don't learn a formula i want you to see
the formula because you're going to have
to use it but don't learn a formula
learn how our volume is created and
realized you can have an infinite set of
infinitesimally thin anything and just
add them up cylinders and neil slices
cylindrical shells whatever you want
whatever you want now we're ready to
actually say the volume equals now I
actually already have a couple of lines
so I'm ready to one continue from there
and I'm going to convert this into an
interval now okay so i'm integrating
from not to and what is it that i'm
integrating this guy here right now i'm
ready to actually say excuse me this is
2pi x then i'm going to substitute in my
H which is four x squared minus X to the
fourth and because I've turned this
integral into integral this is a DX down
rather than Delta X it looks like i can
take out a factor of 2 pi that's nice
then I've got the integral and what's my
integrate 4x cubed minus next to the
five yep DX whoa is this not a hundred
ties simpler than what we had before
when we're dealing with the same
integral same volume rather by annulus
license to buy out the front okay
primitive function next to the 4x to the
six on six multitude yep okay to the
four that's 16 to the 664 16 you
evaluate both of these at zero and you
get zebra let's see here this thing I
can simplified to be 32 on three that's
going to be 48 on three
48 on 348 take away 32 is 16 which I
hope this was recently enough but that
looks familiar okay and vastly superior
to the approach we had to take before
which was a bit of mess okay now like I
said the heading which I asked you to do
after that is volumes by cylindrical
shells in pretty much every case just
like the example I just went through
with you you can do any volume that's by
angular slices you can do by cylindrical
shells right and the question will
usually stipulate for you usually
however there are kind of some clues in
this question now that you know its
political shells are that lean you
towards the fact that cylindrical shells
would have been a better way to go any
suggestions number one it's a polynomial
what else something very anybody about
okay there's this two halves right then
again we often get too much like even if
I had only one part of it when I rotate
around you're gonna get the other bid
right I'm important but yeah McGinnis so
when I usually working on the y-axis get
something that's all the same like
direction of the axis okay yeah yeah so
you're thinking about like what the
actual shape is net you'll get I agree
kind of like when you look at that thing
I think it looks more like a bunch of
bees that it looks like a bunch of of
those right the city fair I can fairly
cut it either way I think the really
important thing is to recognize let's
think about the way an annulus works the
volume is the integral on a to be PI or
we have here now I'm going around the
y-axis hard time right so this is going
to be like some kind of x squared dy and
we know what that's going to that change
because it was in their newest lives
whereas here you've got right there
you've got the why it just is given
already now when I look at this I'm like
I don't know what x squared is we had to
twist and turn we have to use the
quadratic formula do you remember that
possible but hard so look at how things
have been given to you and think about
what you're there for which one is going
to be more efficient so we are suppose
could add another row to this but I
won't do it right now I'm hope i hope
you see the concept okay cylindrical
shells is exercise 6.2 I guess it's
going to so I'll write up some questions
in a second but maybe you need to catch
up on some you're working or whatever I
hope oh here it is I hope my work with
colorful cardboard who azam helpful